if you think America is ready for a
political and economic revolution you
should consider why the rise of Bernie
Sanders isn't freaking out Wall Street
the stock market keeps climbing
despite Bernie status as a clear
front-runner for the Democratic
nomination and given that he's a
self-described Democratic Socialist many
on Wall Street think that a stronger
economy will lead the trump's reelection
particularly if sanders is the nominee
others know that even if sanders manages
to win the white house will have
difficulty enacting medicare for all or
a wealth tax in congress it'll need
filibuster proof majority z' in the
senate or at least the majority or even
moderate democrats are committed enough
to a health care proposal it gets more
unpopular than more people hear about it
and even if bernie succeeds in passing
these policies wall she can still cast
its de facto vote in 2008 a plummeting
doubt convinced Congress to reverse
course and pass the bank bailout 2021 a
similar reaction might give Congress
second thoughts about Bernie's war on
wealth for these reasons wall she doubts
at Bernie's people powered revolution
will actually take place should Wall
Street investors be concerned about a
Sanders presidency let us know in our
poll also let us know what other topics
you'd like our scholars to cover in 60
seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI